our political editor beth rigby reports
on the uk's response there is a warning
her report contains flash photography
nobody sleeps when europe's on the brink
of war isn't russia unstoppable now
the foreign secretary arriving before
sunrise an emergency cobra meeting
convened in the early hours and a
promise to punish putin
if
vladimir putin
continues down this track of a violence
of aggression
of a full-scale invasion of encircling
kiev itself which is what he seems to be
proposing to do capturing the ukrainian
capital it is absolutely vital that that
effort that uh that
conquest of another european country
should not succeed will sanctions be
enough to stop putin prime minister
an attempt to answer that question in
the commons as the pm announced limited
measures sanctions against five russian
banks and three individuals
this is the first trash
the first barrage of what we are
prepared to do and we hold further
sanctions at readiness the labour lead a
full square behind the pm on the
principle but frustrated that strong
rhetoric hadn't translated into enough
real action we must be prepared to go
further
if we do not respond with a full set of
sanctions now
putin will once again take away the
message that the benefits of aggression
outweigh the costs
the complaint that current measures are
not enough widely shared it's not doing
anything said one mp the prime minister
taking notes as all sides of the house
called for heavier harsher measures we
need to hit them if we're going to hit
them with sanctions hard and hit them
now they need to feel the pain of the
first part of this decision president
putin has made a terrible decision
will the prime minister make sure he
pays a terrible price foreign secretary
the sanctions enough
a question being discussed behind this
door as the foreign secretary was
summoned to a second cobra meeting of
the day
sanctions in london british troops to
ukraine's neighbouring borders this was
the pm visiting army personnel in poland
just days ago and today the government
promising more military help if
necessary
as i have warned and warned the kremlin
for weeks and months that
as we knew in 2014
he gets the opposite of what he wants he
will get more forces on his borders and
just as he did in 2014 he will no doubt
get more spending on defense in nato but
for all the rhetoric there was disquiet
in this place today over that package of
sanctions
bringing a peashooter to a gunfight is
how one foreign policy expert put it
this is a significant moment in the
history of the 21st century europe
stands on the brink of war and our
leaders simply don't know whether putin
intends to go on or take a step back
but what we do know is that in years to
come they will be judged on how they met
the moment and whether in that moment
they did enough there's an old military
maxim which is clout don't dribble
and the reason
you should hit hard early
is to make sure you're absolutely clear
that any escalation
will hurt
there's no point in ratcheting up
the pm will be considering the uk's next
move this the end of a very long and
dark day and the beginning of what could
be a protracted and bloody crisis beth
rigby sky news westminster